first rule the moment you start to slide  you're shoveling against the tide what  you need to do is what take a break  here's what's cool about it you can  study for a half hour it doesn't take a  half hour break to recharge your  batteries for most people about five  minutes and this is where you go away do  something fun for five minutes call a  friend talk to a child talk to a parent  a roommate enjoy some music do something  you enjoy and actually say this is my  treat for having studied for 30 minutes  effectively go back and here's what  happens your efficiency is nearly a  hundred percent study a half hour take a  break study a half hour study a half  hour had she done that  over a course of six hours she would  have got about five and a half hours of  serious studying and about a half hour  of total break time